president trump heads to florida to fund
raise today
after a tweet yesterday suggesting the
november election
could be delayed he has no
constitutional power to do that
mr trump also continues to make
unsubstantiated claims that
increased mail-in voting will result in
fraud paula reed is at the white house
paula good morning
good morning jericho the president made
this headline grabbing
suggestion as the headlines were
dominated by
other unfavorable stories a growing
unemployment his sagging polls
and for him the funeral of civil rights
icon
john lewis which the president did not
attend
the president doesn't even have the
power to move the election
that lies with congress where this
suggestion was flatly rejected
do i want to see a day change no but i
don't want to see a crooked election
it was the president's most dramatic
attempt to undermine public confidence
in u.s elections
claiming without evidence that
widespread mail balloting is already
a catastrophic disaster and would lead
to the most inaccurate and fraudulent
election
in history i also don't want to have to
wait for three months and then find out
that the ballots are all missing and the
election doesn't mean anything
republicans including senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell
flatly rejected the idea never in the
history of the country
through wars depressions and the civil
war have we ever
not had a federally scheduled election
on time
and we'll find a way to do that again
this november 3rd as a congressman he
didn't rest
delivering a eulogy at the funeral of
john lewis former president barack obama
warned against those trying to suppress
votes even as we sit here
there are those in power who are doing
their darndest
to discourage people from voting even
undermining the postal service in the
run-up
to an election that's going to be
dependent on mail-in ballots
so people don't get sick president
trump's provocative suggestion came
shortly after news that the u.s economy
shrank at the fastest pace on record
from april to june
and a day after the u.s reached 150
thousand deaths from the virus
on thursday an ardent supporter of
president trump herman cain
died after being hospitalized with kovid
for several weeks
the former pizza ceo and presidential
candidate attended the president's
indoor rally in tulsa on june
20 and was photographed not wearing a
mask or social distancing
kane was considered high risk because of
his previous bouts with liver and
colon cancer in a statement though his
team says they just don't think it's
possible to trace
exactly how he contracted kovid
yesterday president trump called kane a
very special person
vlad all right paula reed for us at the
white house paula thank you very much